es el último capítulo en la evolución de
la crisis política de malí la comunidad
económica de los estados de áfrica
occidental suspendió al país del grupo
regional y pidió a sus gobernantes
militares interinos que nominen a un
nuevo líder civil de inmediato la
decisión llega después de que la nación
viviera un segundo golpe militar en
nueve meses y aprovecho esta oportunidad
para reiterar en nombre de la comunidad
nuestro compromiso continuo con la
transición pacífica en mali
con el objetivo básico de restaurar el
gobierno democrático y trabajar por la
estabilidad del país y de nuestra región
la delegación del grupo regional mantuvo
conversaciones con el líder interino de
malí así migoya en un comunicado emitido
dijo que el país debe cumplir con el
compromiso de celebrar elecciones
presidenciales en febrero próximo guaita
tomó el poder hace una semana después de
que soldados detuvieron al presidente de
transición y el primer ministro pero
luego los liberaron asegurando que
habían renunciado los oficiales habían
sido nombrado
tras un golpe de estado en agosto de
2020 también liderado por goitia y en el
que derrocaron al presidente electo
democráticamente ibrahim bubacar keita
esta no es la primera vez que la
comunidad económica suspende a mali la
medida también fue tomada en 2012 tras
un golpe militar
si bien el derrocamiento de keita en
2020 llevó al bloque a imponer sanciones
las medidas fueron levantadas en octubre